let's talk now about Donald Trump's
position on a lot of this stuff for
someone who says that he doesn't want to
get impeached Donald Trump is really
behaving like someone who is trying to
get Democrats to impeach him we've been
talking a lot about the growing demands
for Trump's impeachment we've been
talking about Trump's behavior exposed
by the Muller report we've been talking
about the strategy behind impeachment
doesn't make sense strategically we've
talked about the ethics behind it but
there is a completely separate issue
that is growing here which is that
Donald Trump's actions in the last two
weeks are starting to force the hands of
Democrats who may end up with no
credible option but to impeach the
President of the United States and if
you're wondering what what is Trump been
doing for the last couple of weeks David
I will tell you what he's been doing the
third article of impeachment against
Richard Nixon I mentioned this in the
last segment we already talked about it
Donald Trump is increasingly a sort of
in contempt of Congress Donald Trump has
directed his administration straight-up
to fight every congressional subpoena to
stonewall every request from Congress
and to make it as close to impossible as
they can for an actual investigation to
take place even Nancy Pelosi who said
she's against impeachment that Trump's
not worth impeachment which angered a
lot of Democrats when she said it and I
think it was March even Nancy Pelosi
said we have to investigate before we
can even say if impeachment is on the
table
and Trump is blocking every single
request that's part of that
investigation and this is a huge part of
why more and more Democrats are now
talking about impeachment I already told
you last week Elizabeth Warren Kamala
Harris Elijah Cummings Maxine Waters
george w bush's former speechwriter aoc
a mix of people in and out of elected
office now Donald Trump is stonewalling
investigations and more names are adding
themselves to the list congressman Jamie
Raskin current member of Congress says I
have a hunch that he is moving the whole
caucus closer to
seeing impeachable offenses what is
Trump stonewalling so far
Trump AG William Bar might not show up
to testify Trump directed all records
requests from the Oversight Committee to
be thought this is the job of the
Oversight Committee and the president is
obstructing them from being able to do
that job the house Intel committee is
trying to look into Donald Trump's
finances the administration is ignoring
all requests the Justice Department
hasn't even responded to document
requests Trump a rather top Justice
Department lawyer John Gore is going to
ignore a subpoena to testify
I challenge so-called constitutional
conservatives who say they believe in
checks and balances put in place by the
founders to just announce this okay if
you're a trumpet of moral substance
maybe there are some out there I want to
hear from you contact me and tell me you
like Trump you want Trump reelected you
love his tax cuts for the rich or
whatever tell me that we have checks and
balances in this country for a reason
and that Donald Trump cannot continue
his behavior here the founders created
the people's house to prevent exactly
this type of autocratic authoritarian
despotism okay despot is a ruler who
holds absolute power typically one who
exercises it in a cruel or oppressive
way Trump doesn't actually have absolute
power but unless someone stops him from
behaving as if he does he has
effectively pragmatically absolute power
and Trump is doing this by saying screw
the law screw the separation of powers
I'm just not going to let the house do
what it was created to do and so much of
what the founders did was meant to stop
presidents from being above the law when
the special counsel says we had
substantial evidence we had eleven
possible obstruction counts but it's
politically messy to indict a president
that makes the president above the law
when the house does the right thing they
request documents the correct way in
order to investigate and the White House
says
nah no documents no testimony that
becomes a white house that is above the
law it's not what Madison wanted it's
not what the founders wanted and this is
actually bigger than Trump which is why
I'm sort of waiting
maybe stupidly maybe naively I'm waiting
for the constitutional conservatives to
say we've had it maybe we voted for
Trump
maybe Hillary would have been worse in
their eyes of course but this is about
the foundational principles of the
country and whether they matter anymore
the right wants these constitutional
fights around like the Second Amendment
which guns can we have based on the
Second Amendment forget for a second
that we have a constitutional right here
that is even more important and it's
about whether the president is totally
immune from consequences for their
actions the founders gave us the tools
impeachment congressional investigations
congressional subpoenas Trump is
ignoring them all and if he's allowed to
do it with no consequences then he is
effectively an unchecked autocrat I'm
ready for the constitutional
conservatives to say no more but I have
a feeling I'm gonna be waiting around
for a long time and that voting in
November of 2020 is going to be a much
faster remedy but I'll say it again if
you're a trump estroux is ready to take
the right moral position and say this
can't continue
checks and balances can't be ignored and
flout it in this way get in touch with
me I want to hear from you make sure
you're following the david pakman show
on instagram at david pakman show we
will have a poll related to this before
you know it
while you're there also follow me I'm on
Instagram at David Pakman we'll take a
quick break and be back after this
support those who support the David
Pakman show and today that includes our
good friends over at BRD Bitcoin wallet
these guys are awesome and the BRD
Bitcoin wallet is absolutely perfect for
anybody who's getting into Bitcoin or
cryptocurrency for the first time
because it was designed with simplicity
and ease of use in mind but you'll also
love it if you have experience with
Bitcoin it's an all-in-one app for iOS
and
Android that lets you buy Bitcoin and
other cryptocurrencies using your credit
card lets you store everything on the
app for free you can trade and sell
cryptocurrency within the app and when
you use BRD wallet you're the only
person who has access to your Bitcoin
BRD doesn't store any of your personal
information you don't even have nor do
you need a username and password on the
platform it's all within an environment
that's virtually impossible to hack so
your cryptocurrency is safe extremely
easy to use
it's how I store my own Bitcoin I think
you'll be impressed with it too it's the
first ever Bitcoin wallet in the iOS App
Store and now they have over 2 million
users for more than 170 countries BR DS
mission is to make buying selling and
storing Bitcoin and other
cryptocurrencies simpler more efficient
and more secure and they've done an
awesome job check out my interview with
Aaron from the BRD team we had a really
interesting discussion about the state
of cryptocurrency going forward you can
also download the BRD app for ios and
android i've put a link right underneath
this video